have you done any shopping lately I'd
shop every day okay well we got the
shopping expert with the deals that you
can get Christian is down with that
program right now all right let me try
here all right thanks guys all right
well it's a 48 hour sale that has many
of us filling up our online cards so for
the first time in Prime Day history
Amazon is hosting a second sale in its
same in the same year now it's called
Prime Early Access sale now the deals
really stretch from home toys pet
products basically it's everyday
essentials but the big question is how
great are the deals so these are some of
the things that we've found today
starting off with the TV we found this
TV here Samsung 75 inch 4K normally the
TV here 31.97 but with today's deals 22
off
24.97 not bad right all right so if
you're into tech gadgets like me so we
found this here the iRobot Roomba I2
model normally it's 389 with today uh
with today's deal 199 so not bad right
all right and as the temperature uh
changes here to the cold weather you
might want to get one of these air
purifiers so we found this model here
normally it's 133 with today's deal 56
percent off you're taking it home for
less than 60 bucks not bad right all
right so if you're looking to upgrade
here I'm talking to you Ted because I
know Kirsten you normally eat out so Ted
If you're looking to upgrade your
cooking skills the ninja now the food
the food Eye five in one indoor grill
with an air fry very popular now
normally it's at 2 30 with today's deals
22 off you're taking it home for 179
guys not bad right Jacob Palmer with
best review says this is a great time
for customers because we don't normally
see these sales until the holidays
it's not only about holiday shopping is
what I mean here people are also using
this event for Halloween uh getting the
final touches for everything they need
for the you know soonest holiday coming
up as well as just stocking up on
everyday essentials we're seeing a lot
of people buying diapers we're seeing
people buying phone chargers
all right retailers no inflation will
have many customers holding back on
holiday purchases Amazon hoping to get
your business with these deals other
deep retailers like Walmart Target and
even Best Buy also jumping in and price
matching some of these items Kirsten